think you've seen all the best
lightsaber battles in the galaxy far far
away well think again the glowing
lightly humming blade has been the
staple weapon of the Star Wars franchise
since its inception in the late 1970s
but somehow despite all the lightsaber
fights that fans of the films have seen
over the years there's one that still
hasn't been shared with the world and
it's apparently the best one ever
Nick Gillard the stunt coordinator for
the Star Wars prequel trilogy recently
revealed to Entertainment Weekly that he
had mapped out a lightsaber battle so
incredible
it would have trumped the one between
obi-wan Kenobi qui-gon jinn and Darth
Maul and the Phantom Menace he explained
that the lightsaber fight that took
place on Utapau and Revenge of the Sith
during which obi-wan battles against
General Grievous and his bodyguards
looked a little different in the
original version of the film before
reading the galaxy of General Grievous
obi-wan Purse needs to dispense of his
bodyguards the theatrical cut of Revenge
of the Sith
sees the Jedi Master using the Force to
pull a piece of the ceiling down on five
of the six bodyguards Grievous sets on
him
however the original version of that
scene would have featured an elaborate
battle royale unfortunately when it came
down to it the production was so far
behind on filming that they couldn't
afford the amount of time the sequence
was going to take to shoot Lucas had to
make a difficult decision
given that the lightsaber battle wasn't
integral to the narrative he decided to
drastically cut down on the scenes
filming time by simplifying the scene
with Grievous's bodyguards fighting with
their electro staffs and obi-wan
wielding his signature lightsaber the
scene promises at the outset to be an
electrified battle a vinyl version does
see obi-wan brace himself for a kind of
all-or-nothing fight but it falls a bit
flat when he disposes of them so
unceremoniously one of the bodyguards
survives obi wan's trickery leaving the
Jedi Master to quickly be cut him in
what we can only assume is a highly
watered-down version of the original
battle if the sequence played out like
Gillard had intended it to it would have
been infinitely cooler despite sounding
like the most epic lightsaber battle of
the Star Wars Canon thus far bands have
never seen it sadly for them it likely
doesn't exist in a cinematic capacity
given that Gillard seems to be implying
that the scene never even made it to the
front of the camera still as
disappointing as Gillard's revelation
may be Revenge of the Sith is full of
some awesome lightsaber battles that
many of the other Star Wars films lack
even if they didn't get in a brawl with
obi-wan the bodyguards get some action
that begin
Revenge of the Sith when Anakin and
obi-wan infiltrate Grievous's spaceship
to rescue Palpatine from Count Dooku
they even seem far more impressive than
their later defeat would seem to apply
as they managed to hold off Anakin and
obi-wan long enough for Grievous to make
a dramatic exit that set-piece also
featured an impressive battle between
Anakin and the Sith Lord Count Dooku
obi-wan later fights Grievous and
finally gets rid of him mace Windu
battles against Palpatine and even Yoda
has his own action-packed face off
against Palpatine in the Senate Plus
fans are treated to a brutally emotional
standoff between obi-wan and Anakin on
Mustafar after he discovers his former
Padawan has gone to the dark side though
George Lucas may have cut the best
lightsaber fights in all of Star Wars
history from Revenge of the Sith he
definitely didn't skimp on Jedi action
whether or not the upcoming Star Wars
flick the rise of Skywalker will provide
fans with a lightsaber battle to fill
the void to the missing scene from
Revenge of the Sith is yet to be seen
still based on the high-flying
lightsaber battles of the last Jedi and
the force awakens were not worried check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]